more American troops are on their way to
the Middle East this morning with
tensions between the u.s. and Iran
growing the Pentagon released new photos
which it says provide additional
evidence with Iran saying that it was
behind the attack on two oil tankers in
the Gulf of Oman acting defense
secretary Patrick Shanahan authorized
about a thousand troops sent to the
region where Iran is now threatening to
breach a key part of the landmark
nuclear agreement David Martin is at the
Pentagon David a thousand new troops in
the region what's their job there good
morning defense officials say the truth
will provide greater defence against
possible missile attacks and additional
surveillance of the Iranian military
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo will be
briefed on the build-up when he visits
Central Command headquarters in Florida
this morning maximum pressure campaign
continues the State Department yesterday
remained determined to keep the heat on
Iran and the orders for more troops came
just as the Pentagon was releasing new
high-resolution photos which officials
say show a crew dressed in Iranian
Revolutionary Guard uniforms attempting
to destroy evidence of the attack on a
Japanese owned oil tanker shortly after
the Pentagon announced the increase in
troops it's sending to the region saying
the u.s. does not seek conflict with
Iran but is working to ensure the safety
and welfare of military personnel in the
region Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
has become the point man for marshaling
international pressure against Iran
we should not yield to nuclear extortion
by the Iranian regime Iran meanwhile
announced it is increasing production of
uranium and will soon go over the limit
it is allowed to stockpile under an
agreement signed by the Obama
administration but disowned by the Trump
administration Iran in a very public way
telling the world that our patience has
run thin and we're going to begin step
by step exceeding the limits set by this
agreement under the treaty Iran is
allowed to stockpile nearly 300
kilograms of low enriched uranium well
short of the 1000 kilograms needed to
produce a nuclear bomb Iran is Calibur
each of these steps to create political
leverage they're not racing towards the
bomb quite yet the US has accused the
run of being behind attacks not just
against the international shipping but
also against US personnel in Iraq and
Afghanistan yesterday three rockets were
fired into an Iraqi military base where
US troops are located fortunately no one
was injured
avianna that's fortunate David thank you
so much